so I've talked enough please I here's
the long line yeah yeah yeah no you are
the best and the brightest and we will
make a picture of them
um
mentioning your name and then the
question is that thing that ends with a
question mark okay
hello my name is Bruno Bruno
first thank you sir Deton as well as the
board of Erasmus and Nexus and drum and
Dad
um sir Dayton your lecture as well as
your books present
pessimists or rather realistic angle of
our social economic structures there is
a problem with capitalism but
are there either individual solutions
that we can as Citizens
put in practice or for the people that
here are heading institutions do you see
also institutional solutions to
capitalism
um
or can it be improved would it be
discarded
or is it too late
no there's certainly not nothing to be
done right otherwise we're all doomed so
there's something to be done and it's
always individuals in the end though
individuals work through institutions
um and again I think the solutions are
probably different than that well the
broad solution of you know capitalism is
coming to an end we can fix it with the
welfare state and Reign inequality which
happened in after the second World War I
don't think anyone knows what the new
thing is going to look like
um and I think
for me in writing this lecture and
thinking about it the sort of
condescension by intellectuals to the
people being left behind has I think
been a terrible problem and I think we
have to listen more broadly and you know
I wish Rob wouldn't use the term their
best and the brightest because the best
and brightest they're the disaster when
they come to run the world you know
[Applause]